os carros
daí a nossa preocupação agora é é a
gente que a gente reveja é conceito de
beleza né tá está beleza transcendente
nossos padrões de 7 quanto ao tempo que
não via uma coisa tão mesmo assim também
é com o nosso projeto objetiva é
inclusão por meio da música
decidi começar a minha fala é um pequeno
exercício no qual é o vôo precisava da
participação de vocês
então a inclusão mesmo a palavra mostrar
o projeto mas se vocês trouxerem
conhecer a música pescador de ilusões do
rappa aqueles que não conhecem o de
chico no rio a letra ou frase pra mim é
mais forte e aí nós vamos começar a
nossa experiência musical do projeto
andrade com isso que espero que vocês
cantem comigo aqueles que não souberem a
letra valente legal é bem simples
é fácil julgar e assim a gente
o motivo que me toca é f
a pena é
valeu a pena ter uma fé
o
bom eu decidi começar com essa música
com a participação de vocês porque ela
foi muito marcante do projeto banda
liberdade e com isso que ela foi eleita
uma das coisas que eu aprendi
esse projeto é que para os sonhos não
existem diferentes e é isso que eu quero
mostrar para vocês hoje trabalha
basicamente em duas gestões sonhos e fé
que estava na noite anterior e os sonhos
que vão ser transmitidos
agora aos poucos como será lo
adolescentes que passaram pelo caso
espaço público cumpriu medida
socioeducativa falar porque praticaram
atos infracionais graves crises graves
transmitidas passaram pelo projeto
quando a liberdade ea divulgação desse
projeto proporcionou a esses três jovens
que já tinham saído da unidade conhecer
os estúdios da globo em são paulo
viajar de avião coisa que talvez não
conseguisse captar uma lista pela cidade
passar por essa experiência maravilhosa
é uma coisa que os meninos no avião e
ele causa da turbulência em forte não se
segurou e aí estava com vontade de
comunitário não tinha tal possa amanhã
em goiás e segura pra ele te acalma vai
chegar ao aeroporto
após o registro audiovisual de todos os
momentos que a gente está passando
importante do projeto é pelo tempo na
elite
eu sou quando é o próprio violência né
foi feito o caminho eo eu poderia cair
não foi a primeira que eu sou tudo
porque eu sou o evento começou ainda
criança quando a mãe o pai e não deus
mesmo que aparece muitas vezes algumas
situações sonhos realizados
eu gostaria que você vai acompanhar esse
projeto
para fechar a noite o
eu ia muito bacana ele ia passar o
antigo o vídeo diretamente no bolso
ele olha só
você sabe se o aparelho não pensei que
se trata essa história aqui que é o
direito de um pouquinho pra todo mundo é
essa de seu personagem
por favor da wii
tenho dinheiro eu quero que você se
apresentasse o pessoal da escola é só
isso
o que significa isso que eu falei lá
atrás
o projeto piloto de verdade é um projeto
que objetiva transformar a vida de
adolescentes que compreendia sócio
pela prática de atos infracionais
o correto é errado
o usuário é cada um saber o momento de
esforço nacional
eu ia às vezes eu não sou nem eu eles
cometeram mas eu acredito sim que ele
escolhesse a gota d
como diria o
então faz questão de colocar o projeto
na verdade
mesmo com os bichos em razão disso é o
espaço não é curto
no palco o rappa não errar no brasil só
pela música que faz a primeira vez em
que morava no brasil decidir construir
o mundo
a unidade mesmo que puni los
é muito difícil fazer isso eu falo é
muita gente mas é porque o sonho pode
possibilitar para uma pessoa que foi um
músico forçado nenhum percentual total
meu nome é mais que se diga na mídia dá
pra música então minha fala vai ser um
pouquinho dos meus sonhos é como ela é
pequena quando era criança só foi um
sonho de bola com as crianças
brasileiras jogador de futebol
todas as crianças brasileiras por causa
do esporte favorito não é jogador de
futebol que joguei na escolinha do meu
coração que responde pelo internacional
e marquei futebol sido dessa vitamina e
até o negócio
de qualquer forma fiquei um torcedor
fanático né
de maneira que quando na década de 80 o
nosso rival estava bem até que eu veja
também eu tinha que suportar toda aquela
preciosa que reúne power lá em cima e eu
sofrendo 2000 isso virou e aí eu pude
levar minha mãe e meu irmão em 2006 por
japão e concretizar o sonho de muitos
colorados jamais imaginou que poderia
acontecer
quero um dia ser campeão mundial e
segundo poderoso barcelona é um sonho de
criança que foi se desenvolvendo e
acabou complexidade combinando neste
momento é é ainda depois da meta dessa
massa de criança na adolescência aí uma
saída do futebol e foi pra música não
constava o ok que queria ser uma banda
de rock que ia fazer sucesso com a
música
poderia ser uma uma forma importante de
tocar as pessoas de influenciar as
pessoas mas também não era certo eu
tentei é daqui declarou ramos no entanto
é em são francisco de paula na serra e
fica um negócio não ia dar muito certo e
fui estudar direito na faculdade e então
comecei a ter a partir do início do
curso um outro sonho eu fui muito
influenciado por maiores cristãos por
parte da minha mãe especialmente a
questão da solidariedade e ajuda ao
próximo é da qualidade e então esses
valores junto com uma má influência
política no sentido de querer trabalhar
para o estado é um pouco da minha
família e de repente tem lógica política
era de seu funcionário público de
trabalhar com o estado
ele estava com um objetivo bem comum ea
maioria das pessoas trabalhando com
estava dentro do direito eu imaginei que
poderia ser mesmo um juiz de direito que
foi a figura do meu irmão que também já
era feliz por meu pai mas aí depois
acabou saindo do escritório fazendo com
que os portugueses eu cresci vendo a
figura ele a importância que ele tinha é
na família e na sociedade
o exercício dessa função cinco anos de
curso de graduação em direito
tudo muita medicação um ano de escola
superior da magistratura mais um ano
dois anos de preparação
daí vão precisar sim um sonho
profissional que estava vigente não só
se implantava durante muito tempo
então é com a posse como juiz de direito
no pleno do tribunal de justiça do rio
grande do sul perante o grande nome do
estado é o presidente do tribunal o
presidente da assembléia legislativa
então é aquilo que muitos colegas fatais
talvez acharam graça quando perguntavam
o que eu queria ser eu queria ser juiz
de direito
achava que não era possível eu sei que o
quadro é aquilo de que com a medicação
um esforço consegue alcançar qualquer
tipo de sonho é tocar com o rappa jamais
fez parte de qualquer tipo de sonho
pessoal grande como o planeta mas ficou
por aí
com isso que a gente tem para aqueles
que a gente não tenha ainda não existem
é como juiz de direito
eu fiz essa sensação direito da criança
e do adolescente ea partir daí é criei
nem a idéia de juntar esses dois sonhos
na função de juiz de direito com aquela
sensação inicial que ela trabalha a
música então que ia fazer algum projeto
relacionado à música que crianças e
adolescentes
marcou muito o aniversário de 70 anos da
minha mãe que ela não é como o que você
vai fazer todos aqueles valores ela
fizemos só em porto alegre uma festa no
restaurante a história é considerado
está um projeto seu sonho eu não quero
um presente pra mim eu quero só os
bordados nos lêem técnicos entreguem os
mesmos locais que possam depois do
tratamento esse projeto
então recebemos todos os instrumentos
dispenso os convidados comprarmos
entregaram no dia do aniversário de 70
anos ela estava em julho naquela época
não era justo em fazenda energia uma
vara cível a e depois disso acabei
ficando com que os instrumentos não
conseguir concretizar o projeto naquele
momento me evoluir passo fundo com o
juiz da infância e lá em passo fundo eu
fiquei com o responsável por uma unidade
de internação de adolescentes em razão
da prática de atos infracionais graves
a unidade que ética passagem a 40
adolescentes mas que muitas vezes tinha
80 90 quando já tinha mais de 100
adolescentes e fui conhecer quais eram
os projetos desenvolvidos naquela
unidade
se o pedagogo da época então me sair até
1 e mostrou os projetos praiano já nem
se tinha profissionalização tinha lesão
do esporte
e aí comentam sobre a proposta de fazer
um projeto oficinas de música dentro da
unidade
é isso que eu quero eu tenho
instrumentos um tinha a barba com os
documentos pessoais
aqueles que tinham sido doados em razão
do aniversário da minha mãe e filha a
atuação desses instrumentos para a
unidade do projeto pois é conseguiu
recursos é outros pra que a gente
comprasse outros instrumentos e também o
seu recurso para que a gente pudesse
impactar os professores e assim começou
de forma primitiva né e simples muito
simples
o projeto planta liberdade que uniu
essas duas decisões
só que sem recurso escasso e esse
projeto começou a ser divulgada
parece uma primeira matéria da rbs em
porto alegre
depois daquilo teve uma certa divulgação
faz o projeto acabou morto parou e foi
retomado
assim com força
especial porque no ano passado nós
começamos a discutir o brasil novamente
a questão da redução da maioridade penal
é como se o professor de direito não
fazer da infância e professores gente
funcional
eu revi alguns textos e artigos e
caminha para meios de comunicação para
explicar por que razões jurídicas e por
que razões políticas no brasil seria
impossível reduzir a maioridade penal
acontece eu não consegui infelizmente é
da trânsito e publicação a esses textos
de maneira que eu decidi então mostrava
o que se faz na sua educação na
responsabilização dos adolescentes e que
não existe um sistema prisional o
sistema dos maiores dos alunos
por isso então nós refizemos a matéria
do projeto modalidade que aquela matéria
então feita é do jornalista manoel
soares da ideia de porto alegre ganha
uma dimensão maior
chegou o convite para que a gente
pudesse primeiro fazer a partir daí a
escolha a do rio tem conhecidos no mundo
também dentro do sistema prisional no
rio acreditamos na arte como uma forma
de ressocialização queremos eu equipe é
possível fazer para apoiar o projeto é e
disse mais como uma empresa com rafa
o chile quer falar contigo porque ele
acha que uma pode apoiar os seus do ano
instrumentos do ano o material é também
a ajudar e ser contribuintes nesse
projeto e aí conseguimos então por
exemplo aqui logo que eu existir né não
tínhamos capacidade e condições de fazer
esse trabalho e aqui no estúdio da globo
o pessoal da globo fez o que tinha que
aparecer um problema é o quanto a
liberdade mas como é que está a marca de
vocês e de marca estão aí então o
pessoal logo fez nos deu o que a gente
usa camiseta do marcante da banda de
internet
a pergunta que significou para mim né
como vício juiz federal é e na infância
é é possível retificar alguém na vida do
crime
essa pergunta é uma crescente a cada
situação do crédito habitacional
pergunta que se faz é que estava
transitando que hoje é impossível
retirar as pessoas nessa situação de
invisibilidade que existe muitas vezes
nessa situação de miséria dessa situação
de pobreza essa situação de violência
essa é a questão está subjacente ao
projecto quando na verdade a
responsabilização que apresente a
responsabilização de adultos com a
prática do crime
o que eu faço questão de trabalhar com
vocês
também com essa questão da fé e da
esperança né
é preciso sim acreditar é preciso ter fé
no ser humano jamais existiu e todos os
presentes que eu peguei por mais frios
que eram termos de perfil de atos
infracionais
eu jamais desistir de tentar
ressocializados de tentar só cedo caos
por ajudar de alguma forma com algum
tipo de internação e elas têm que ser as
mais variadas possíveis abusos que
apenas uma delas é importante que a
gente possa explorar o potencial das
pessoas e cada uma das possibilidades
que existe pessoal pode não gostar de
música e de repente pode gostar do
esporte no brasil em
o vôlei totalidade eu sou
necessariamente é melhor que ela fez ela
vive uma fase pobre que ela tem que
trabalhar na construção civil
então a gente quer desistir mas há um
trabalho também não precisa
necessariamente ser servente de pedreiro
ser pedreiro ou seja precisa então um
aluno da universidade de uma aula é
depois de ver o projeto professor e quer
fazer alguma coisa também optou nos
restaurantes
agora chega à europa trabalhei lá também
e é o que eu gostei muito e ficou
dividido em trazer minha experiência
então fizemos um projeto de auxiliar de
cozinha para ensinar os meninos a
certeza a partir de g
dentro de uma mãozinha como é esse
trabalho só em deus mas achei depois a
preparar porque ele é repente podem
explorar o potencial de um dois ou três
que estão aí é que podem ser trabalhar
sobre essa perspectiva sobre esse mês se
desenvolveu como no caso é a reinserção
social privado de liberdade em vários
aspectos que são importantes e devem ser
trabalhados são paulo o jornal é a
integração social de aproximar se
retirar
em tempo o título é delinquente em
colocar ele de que a etiqueta ter música
de artista
então aqui um projeto de drenagem estava
é projeto meu bairro a prefeitura a
semana com a sociedade
aquino maria opinião portal r7 e aqui o
gabriel morena congresso
este é um bicho eu gostaria que vocês
vissem apenas com o aspecto da letra o
quanto é importante que a transformação
da música pode a apresentar esse projeto
não é verdade
a montanha é assunto